porn pyramids preposterous probably the
10 minute long video is actually shot
last year but recently found fame when a
local paper published a report about the
video paired with screen shots from the
film officials originally denied the
film's authenticity but have since
changed course
alright so I've been to Egypt I've been
to the pyramids there actually while
they are incredible absolutely
incredible astounding to look at there's
not that much going on there actually
unfortunately there is now
exactly now there is but the British
actually took most of the stuff like
that that's all in the British Museum's
but this part of the world isn't this
what they need more than anything else
we were just talking about women in this
part of the world but don't they need to
be okay with sex like to me that seems
like the linchpin that will if you get
if you get that how we might start
getting okay with everything else yeah
they need it but I mean this is like a
very it's like zero to you know a
hundred type of like being okay with
this porn that's something that you
consider to be kind of special yeah so
you think that's too much I thought you
were gonna say that you were okay with
sort of like push I mean like I would
love for them to be more open about sex
and sexuality and you know rights and
all of that but I think that this is
just gonna push them in the exact
opposite direction yeah yeah I mean
being like but are you okay with this I
just picture like a lot of family photos
and family albums like having like
really awkward backdrops you know with
like different positions in the back
like what did you do on your vacation
I don't know and what was that like
awkward nip slip that she had like that
was that the flashing no I think you got
a little bit God there was a full sex in
their life it wasn't looking for it yes
yeah if you know where the actual I just
want to be able to talk about it with
more you know yeah surely you're you're
a pro and you want to research the
topics appropriately and I appreciate
that
with everyone walking around we're all
walking around with cameras and phones
in all this we should expect this stuff
like viewing there will be any place
that's really considered a holy site
like five more years from now there's
going to be porn shot pretty much
everywhere right I mean I think so and I
mean why not like it no I think there's
gonna be like porn in the Vatican I mean
they're actually probably doing it but
it's not being recorded as open-minded
and pro body and sex as I am like it's
still like you gotta keep some things a
little off yeah you gotta keep some
things a little protected like family
attractions yeah right have some respect
so even though that was my one
conservative yeah that was the most
conservative thing so you're saying that
even though the pyramids aren't a
religious thing so but you're just
saying just as a National Monument kind
of thing yeah most likely there are
children there yeah do you think though
do you think this is a little bit of it
feeds the idea to the people there that
the West is an evil see you see what
they do they come over here saying
before like it's it's like push you in
the opposite direction it's too much you
know yeah I really thought you're gonna
be you know there's a balance to things
yeah so so the porn people the people
that hate porn then you're secretly
watching the most more night is that I
mean yeah they're usually the ones
secretly in the forum they're in the war
that you can't find so you know what do
you make of the porn people there
there's a through line here with
fundamentalism they find people that are
fighting against something or the people
that are doing it behind closed doors
yeah I mean I think people are just
afraid of these types of things like it
just scares them they think it's
horrible and evil even though they're
secretly kind of like it you're like
someone that someone is judging them so
they have to not like it even though
they kind of do yeah well we're judging
you people unless you comment right now